all right
[Music]
so uh hi everyone and welcome to our
first meetup for 2022
we are by data hamburg and we are very
happy to have you here with us
now a quick disclaimer in case you are
joining us for the first time and you
already don't know this um this session
is being recorded
and will be posted on pi data's youtube
channel
so if you're not comfortable having your
voice or face on the internet
please disable your camera and your
microphone but of course you can still
participate right so if you have any
questions
write them on the chat and they will be
addressed
you might also want to consider if you
would like to rename yourself
now in addition to writing questions on
the chat you can also raise your hand
and one of our moderators kind of new so
you know whatever you prefer
uh
about a little bit about pi data
we are a global community of developers
and users of open source data tools that
are written in python
and behind pipe data is num focus a
us-based non-profit that promotes open
practices in research data and
scientific computing
they're sponsoring projects like numpy
pandas jupiter right so do go check them
out and who knows maybe consider even
giving them a donation
now you can also see our media channels
here social media channels
feel free to go there share your
thoughts about today's meetup and you
can also go to the youtube channel where
you will find out uh you'll find other
meetups and not just from our chapter
but also from pi data chapters from all
over the world
we can have a maybe a quick meet and
greet from the team behind pi data
hamburg
um obinna
um
alex
uh yeah
alex is also here with us tonight
myself i'm daphne hi
um kaity
hello hi
and camilla
hello
so um your host for today would be kaity
alex and myself
and
here's our call out for you so um in
case you would like to give a talk you
know about anything regarding open
source data tools we would love to host
you especially if you're a first time
speaker like don't be shy reach out to
us you can do that through our social
media channels or just directly come to
one of the organizers
we're also always happy to have more
volunteers on board so if you think you
can help with the meter planning do
reach out
and even if you don't have the time for
volunteering but do but have a speaker
in mind right that you would like to
recommend just do it we'd really love to
hear from you
now before we continue um camilla would
like three minutes of your attention
okay
so
i would like to just ask three minutes
of your attention for a very important
topic uh
at least i think it's very important
and
it's a human to human conversation you
know it's very friendly very relaxed
that we are going to talk about
diversity equity inclusion and the thing
is i know when i talk about diversity
and inclusion some people already
standing up going to get water people
already looking there i will just ask to
stay here with me for this little bit
for this moment
and the thing is uh
you know
all of us uh working in tech we can take
a little bit of a small action to try to
improve diversity equity inclusion uh in
this year of 2022 we can all make a
difference
and that's why i would like to give some
tips
on different uh agents of this tech
world and how you can contribute to have
a little bit more of diversity equity
inclusion in 2022 and beyond so
first for the meet up organizers
uh thing is
representation matters just imagine
i am
a cat lover
and then i go to a meetup there is only
dog lovers the speakers are dog lovers
the organizing team are dog lovers the
participants are dog lovers dog lovers
everywhere i as a cat lover i feel a
little bit you know out of place
bird lovers fish lovers
you know elephant lovers i mean it just
doesn't feel that very welcoming
so and i know as a meetup organizer it
can feel a little bit overwhelming
because it's a lot of work sometimes you
really need to be proactive and going
knock on the door of the people trying
to ask hey can you give a talk please
are you available it's a lot of no's
that you get it's overwhelming
but it's important and especially
because you are a meet-up organizer it's
a kind of part of your responsibility to
try to make everyone welcome in the
community right
uh and it's also quite a question of
like if you only have dog lovers in your
organizing team perhaps you started your
meet up two three years ago
it's very difficult because then you
find a cat lover elephant lover i look i
looked your organizing team and i'm like
i don't feel like i would be welcome in
that community so it's things that
perhaps you should you know like when a
taking mind
and what i would like to maybe give a
recommendation is how can you address
that because it's not easy there are
ways you can do it so the first of all
is trying to ask the community so it's
about the community community is the
answer to all of the problems so if you
ask the community community can you give
a recommendation on uh different
speakers would anyone like to be part of
the organizing team try to bring the
community in and try to ask help that's
one thing
what you can do it's also there are so
many different online platforms just go
through these different online
communities and platforms so it's like
it's called you name it and just go
there and promote your meetup and say
hey i'm looking for speakers and people
you see like oh they are you know like
just trying to do the thing in the right
way and it will be easier for you
and of course there are always the
excuses because how many times have you
heard for example
cat lovers are not qualified cat lovers
don't come to my meetup
cat lovers oh we can't find them you
name whatever animal you would like and
not saying that it's excuse but there
are ways you can address it again if you
really try to make the effort to go to
different communities and
try to make people from other
communities feel welcome in your event
everything will be
fine in the end and again it's important
to have this responsibility as people
working tech right not only for a more
diverse
and equity inclusion backward or
whatever but in general right so that's
one part of it i would like now to talk
a little bit to the event participant
and we have two elements in there we
have the
attendee and we also have the speaker
for the attendee it takes a lot of
courage sometimes to stand up and say
hey
uh in your event there are only
dog lovers what are the bird lovers
elephant lovers and so on and so on so
it's sometimes also a lot of toe in a
particular group if they always have to
do this effort to stand up and say about
things
but again it's worth you can do that
anonymously you can have a fake profile
or sometimes you know like you just go
there and give the feedback it's always
depend what is on the stake if you can
give that feedback or not but it's
important also the allies they can
really help on that so if you go to an
event and you only see that's the same
kind of people you know like dog lovers
or whatever lovers there
just stand up and say hey perhaps we can
all of work together to have more
diversity in there
so that's for the attendees
speakers the best speakers i saw so far
they say clearly i don't go to an all
dog lovers event they make a statement i
love that that's it
and that's how they start to help on the
change because the thing is if it's
common to everyone right just to say
okay i go there to the dog lover event
oh it's cool all the dog lovers wow wow
wow it would never change
so this is a small thing you as a
speaker you can do you just say hey i go
to your event but i bring someone else
with me is that fine or i'm so sorry
but again
give grace
take a look it's the first time they're
organizing that meeting perhaps you give
a chance but if you go there and you
took a look for the past two years of
online events they only had dog lovers
red flag red flag red flag so take a
look on that and try to make the change
uh
and finally i would like to uh talk as
well
and i'm part of this group it's all of
us we are all biased that's the thing
we tend to gravitate to people that look
like us
and it's a you know a really conscious
effort that you need to make to step
back and try to say okay
i have friends from different
communities different religions
different opinions and so on and so on
but it's a lot of effort again because
it's just you know like our brain is
lazy it's just too easy to say okay i'm
going to accommodate and do the thing
like that
so what you can do and it's not only for
the tech world especially for the whole
world because this is really about
building tolerance between different
people you know and this is very
important for a lot of reasons that i
don't think i have to explain that hang
out with different people how you can
hang out with different people so first
now it could be times it's a little bit
different but traveling is a great way
to do that you can read books from
people that are not like from your same
community let's say you're a dog lover
you can go there to the cat lover
whatever animal over you of your choice
but open your mind to different
communities
and learning about different cultures is
wonderful way to to do that and one way
that i have been doing that for the past
15 14 years of my career is being part
of different mentoring programs
and as a mentee as a mentor and that
helped me so much to open my mind to
different realities
uh and i can give one practical example
that this was for me really one i think
a transformative experience if you want
to call that one of my mentees in a
country i'm not going to tell you which
one it is
they couldn't sell their products in a
particular store because of who they are
they were discriminated
but then you had in your privilege you
will listen to that and you're like
that stuff so that helps you or that
at least gives a little bit of push to
try to devocate a little bit
for people that some perhaps doesn't
have the same privilege as you so that's
one part of it that's what i learned
from mentoring so if you can i don't
know if you have seen about it uh there
are many uh mentoring programs you can
join i'm running the one at my word this
one
is specifically focusing on bringing
more uh
women into technology pi data just
launched now uh the global impact
mentoring program this is for free 100
places so you can apply to be a mentee
you can be a mentor that's not only a
way of course to you know like of course
it is also you're going to get your
personal development professional
development but that's a wonderful way
also to build a little bit more of
tolerance diversity equity inclusion in
the stack world and again
341 days until the end of the year we
all can take a little bit of action you
can choose i think i gave tips to all of
us that you can choose whatever you want
to do but we can all make a difference i
think this time it was more than
three minutes but thank you so much
all right thank you camilla
that is actually a very important topic
maybe we can talk about it a bit more at
the end of the networking session
uh let's resume now for now
uh so um our agenda for tonight
first up is ayola giving her talk then
we'll have a 10 minute break around 7
50.
after the break we continue with malte
and finally around 8 40 we'll have an
open discussion and networking ground
so now um i
can
pass you on to kaity
um
we can start
yes welcome everybody welcome thank you
so much for uh ayola olaf fenwa to
give up his talk about the role of
artificial intelligence in creating
intelligent machines
so
back a little bit background of ayola is
um
[Music]
ayola is a self-taught programmer a
technical writer and a deep learning
practitioner for five years of
experiences in object oriented
programming
um she works as a machine learning and
cloud engineer at deep quest ai where
she works on building and deploying
machine learning applications in the
cloud
she has developed two open source
computer vision projects
that are used by many developers around
the globe across the globe
in this talk she will walk us through
the definition of ai its of evolution
building intelligent machines
and contributions of artificial
intelligence in different fields such as
healthcare agriculture business and the
automobile industry
so the floor is yours ayola
looking forward
thank you so much for the introduction
can everyone hear me
hi
okay good great
thank you so much for the introduction
so let me start my presentation
[Music]
for me
and now in this talk i'm going to speak
about the world of artificial
intelligence in creating intelligent
machines we will talk about what
artificial intelligence is
a brief uh explanation of the evolution
of ai
the different approaches that are used
in creating intelligent machines some of
the versions of air despite his work
the ai episodes projects i have built on
the contributions of ai
first of all what is artificial
intelligence
artificial intelligence is the ability
of martian to stimulate human
intelligence an ai works towards
creating an intelligence machine that is
capable of so sorry i'm so sorry i'll
have to stop i have gone to the wrong
slide so sorry
sorry
that's no problem because then i can
make a screenshot again you were too
fast
okay let me start okay thank you so much
so what is artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence the ability of
machines to stimulate my intelligence
may i work towards placing natural
intelligence in machines to enable
machines to solve problems like roma's
artificial intelligence and emerging
field of science and has cosmic relates
to different aspects of life
particular intelligence techniques are
used by medical professionals in finding
solutions to health problems
ai has also been used
in
creative vision self-driving cars 25
different cars maneuver like build human
divers ai has been used creating machine
translation which is the ability of a
machine to translates from one language
to another we are also used ai to create
uh natural sound speech in a assistant
that communicates with humans with
assistants like sana siri alexa and
grouping assistance
the evolution of artificial intelligence
began in 1940s and 1950s alonso was one
of the early computer scientists that
work on ai
in his work he published a glad mark
paper titled composing machinery and
intelligence which was published in
1915.
he asked an intensive question called
machine stink
answering by this question assigned to
others prospects of crazy and
intelligent machine that is capable of
solving problems like hormones
this made into crazy tests known as the
story test
the turin test
is used as a benchmark to test a machine
that can exhibit intelligence the twin
test is based on the idea of a machine
that can solve a problem in social way
that whenever's differentiates whether
this problem is solved by a woman
or a machine it is smaller than they
were successfully used ais case
detergent mushrooms that are close to
passing student tests
so
um
different approaches are being used in
creating artificial intelligence and
some of the major approaches that have
been used recently are machine learning
and deep learning
now first i will talk about machine
learning machine learning is a fade of
artificial intelligence that deals with
how we teach machines to learn
in machine learning we decided to apply
the uma learning procedure to teach
to obtain knowledge and enable them to
solve problems like humans we should
observe this natural intelligence when a
child is born a child is born with no
knowledge of anything the child
improving knowledge by stolen by
environments by going to school the
person is able to solve mathematical
problems by learning mating matters the
same principle is also applied in
machine learning machine learning
algorithms are built to serve as
guidelines for machines to learn
these algorithms which make this
possible for machines to process
information
to enable them to learn god's valley
just like the way human within until
able to master to solve a particular
skill
data is the source of information that
is used to obtain machines
the data can be regarded as a book of
knowledge from which a machine blend
and we can get machine learning
algorithms as t-shirts that teach
information from data to matching data
into in different forms it can be
virtual data it started from images of
videos teach machine to you know
understand the environment to see
objects to identify nice objects it can
be test data is started from tests
to teach our machines to understand
human languages and it can also be audio
data it started for module 5 strategy
machine to understand human space
if implementing the feed of artificial
intelligence that deals with creating
newer networks to build machine learning
models
your networks are the algorithms that
are designed
to blend relation that
exists among data to establish
information from data and produce a
target aspect
when networks are designed after the
model of the human brain the human brain
is made up of billions of neurons that
are connected to each other that ensure
the coordination of human activities the
same principle is applied in new orleans
which are used in building machine
learning models it is dagger
representation of neural network we can
see a same sample in our network this
new oneness has an input layer this is
the password data is obtained
and this information
is starting from this data and pass
through a series of easy layers where
the information is
first
and
finally we get a
a final aspect layer where the tag gets
asked which is produced the oneness
networks have helped a lot increasing uh
machine learning models that make it
possible for us to create intelligent
machines
conversational networks are one of the
major types of newer network used in
facing machine learning models
artisan intelligence has different
branches but in this stop i'm going to
talk about the three common branches
which are natural language processing
speech recognition and computer vision
national language processing also known
as nlp is a bunch of artificial
intelligence that deals with crazy
intelligent machines that are capable of
understanding human languages we use new
one networks like gru's transformers
lstms to process test data estimated
from purpose of tests
to use neural networks
i start using information from
data and make it possible for machines
to understand human languages
national grade processing is an
important field of ai and just consider
immensely different aspects it has made
it possible to have machine translation
which is the ability of an intelligent
machine to translate foreign language to
know that using nlp were able to create
an ai that can translate from french to
english
it has also created a feed known as
sesames analysis
settlements analysis is the analysis of
demand tests this can be like the
analysis of
a product or visual review so the timing
gives this video is analyzed as positive
or negative
natural language processing has also
been used increasing ai that is
generating tests and summarizing tests
like moments
learning from the world of light
language models where we have in life
language models like gps tv but open ai
that is capable of generating
astonishing tests like woman's versa of
value also by opening address capable of
generating images from
tests specific population is not a bunch
of artificial intelligence that this
means 481 networks
that will be able to uh process
information from audio teachers to
recognize we must
use neural network like wavelengths diff
speech to establish useful information
from audio data containing human speech
and make this information readable to
machines
advanced aspects of this recognition we
have speech to test test speech
speech to test the bash of special
population that just with converting
our monitors to speech and special
completion we have been about mobile
phones special application
that's feature tests with new devices
that are capable of converting our
speech tests from all many of our mobile
phones like androids iphones by really
downloading any app of the play store to
convert our speech to tests we also have
test speech tests which is the bunch of
special population that this is
conversing human racing tests to speech
to natural sound displays
the google cloud test speech uses
wavenet's newer networks
converts
tests to over 100
um voices in multiple languages this
occupation has also been used in
creating air assistance like siri alexa
and google assistant that are capable of
communicating with women's natural sound
speech
computer vision is a bunch of artificial
intelligence that disputes giving
machines the capability to see like
humans in computer vision
increase neural networks that are
capable of establishing information from
virtual data which can be studied for
images or features and make it possible
for us to keep an intelligent machine
that is capable of saying analyzing
identifying and satisfying objects like
umass
has
community
branches i'm going to speak about the
common patches from product vision which
are image classification object
detection and object segmentation
image classification
is a bunch of computer visions that this
using new oneness online west to their
network exception networks to establish
useful information from images and make
it possible for us to create a machine
learning model that's capable of
classing objects and images and leaders
in other detection we are concerned
about identifying
locating attacking objects in images and
videos we use neural nets for like dolo
retina nets faster off cnn to extract
this information from mixing video and
make it possible to place an air
conscious of locating of the education
and tracking objects images and video
you also have projected i'll object
segmentation auto segmentation is the
punch of computer vision that is
measuring with analyzing objects in
object segmentation we classify objects
at a pixel level
this segmentation we try to define other
different segments so that it can be
analyzed the approaches and object
supplementation make it a very important
aspect of computer fusion by using some
physical uh computer efficient related
problems like an health care subject
because
i'm not just supplementation we have we
have new on this one like mass austin
and points to it that are used for
segments objects images and videos
as part of my work i have created two
open source ai projects which are pixel
demand already the first one is pcle
peso lip is an open source computer
vision products i built using python
programming language framework and its
uses tensorflow and deep and
priceless deep learning libraries it
makes it possible for anyone with
limited knowledge of artificial
intelligence able to get obvious
segmentation india software solutions
basically music possible perform objects
segmentation use a few lines of pricing
code instantly was released as a
vital package and firefighter in may
2016
in january 2022
recently supports semantic segmentation
of objects and images
method segmentation is a bunch of object
segmentation that deals with analyzing
of multiple objects of the same class as
a single identity
this kind of objects segmentation
if there are five people in an image
each of these five people will be
analyzed as a single class
and this is used for a lot of solving
critical uh problems in medical
and in
self-driving class
the celebrations develop simatic
segmentation architecture for performing
schematic segmentation of objects images
and videos is it five days of pricing
code basically makes it possible to
perform similar segmentation one of 50
classes of objects
and
was able to achieve some fps using
target sets of five months by five
months on nvidia g4 gtx 1650
this image sound was submitted by this
elite because signaling our isolate was
able to symmetrically segment different
objects in this image the three objects
are outlined separately the building
objects the cast from just the people
objects and likewise the sky cloud this
kind of technique that's used in
autonomous vehicles and
other numerous factors to analyze their
driving environments
essentially supports instant
segmentation of objects eastern
segmentation is a bunch of artificial
intelligence that deals with
segmentation of multiple
instances
of the same organ this kind of
segmentation
if multiple instantaneous objects are
treated as different eye sentences
for example in an image if we are five
people if it is similar to segmentation
all these five people
seated at a single identity
but in instant segmentation each of the
passing this image will be treated and
analyzed uniquely differently from other
people
usually this is points are must ask them
for resistance segmentation of objects
in images and videos
it makes it possible to perform instant
segmentation using five lines or python
was able to achieve 9 fps you see a
target size of 5 of 250 by 200 on nvidia
g4 gts system 15.
this is an an image sample segmented by
pcli you can see that there are
different objects in this image and
that's the main difference between
instance segmentation from smart
segmentation let us observe it from the
object's persons
there are multiple objects in this image
with a signal that each of the objects
person is giving a distinct color which
means another person a will be analyzed
and seated immediately by the air
defending from other objects persons
these are the other supports for
continuing segmentation model this is
possible to send
segmentation modes using mass also using
soundness of python code i sent
basically on a data set of
containing images of spoilers and
butterfly and the same segmentation
model was able to successfully detect
and segment product line as chorus these
are the image samples we can see how
the 10 segmentation model was able to
segment and detect the objects for the
flights as far as in this sample
images listen it also makes it possible
to extract segmented objects
imagine you say yo there's an image
sample with multiple objects
apart from the fact that we segment the
objects mean half objects of incest
that's relatively science
resource situation we can just establish
our objects of interest this only makes
this possible using five that's python
was able to start segmented objects in
images and features because it is image
sample
the best sequence here is
a started act as a wall as same as a
separate image
isolate also uses smart segmentation
techniques to perform vanguard editing
working on the principle of object
segmentation in which we deal with
analyzing objects deficiency between
foreign
and bangladesh objects i was able to use
segmentation techniques to
segment objects establish segmented
objects from the abundance and place
their new plungers basically abandoned
it's the features include collide
vanguard of images and features
basically the bandgames and leaders
facing a virtual bandit for images and
leaders learning the band of images and
leaders and this bangladeshi future was
able to achieve so you have
panel sets of
5.5.2 on the video g4 tts system facing
in this image sample we can see an image
say
edited the same image with the blood
bandana
followed by an image with a virtual
pancreas virtual abandoned
then a colored bandgame and a
waste-killed banger
always link is my second computer vision
projects are used for classifying
objects
it's also based on python program
language network and this is the test of
the deep learning library
i changed classification models using
mobileness oneness architecture
and i was able to classify why when
arrived oranges like
bananas with and being artists using
orange link
artificial intelligence as common
gateways to different aspects of life
and first of all talk about the
constitution of artificial intelligence
medical field
asian intelligence as a state medical
professional defines solutions to
challenging health problems medical
imaging is an aspect of that vision that
is used together with other vertical
techniques to study human body
we have ai techniques that are used with
medical techniques like essay with the
graphic mri and the scope to store the
human internal organs and tissues
air has also been used by scientists
surprise skin cancer to defensive
calcium
calcium skin cell ai applications have
been used
in
fighting with the 19 by ensuring people
with diagnosis in patients
you have amazing ai admissions for
medical purposes for example
we have tightened by your surgical the
next is possible to monitor the amount
of dirt dust during a surgical operation
after food is an amazing air invention
by deep mind
that was able to solve a 50-year medical
challenge of predicting outputting
suctions are formed in human bodies
after falling
back to as pathway for solving political
health problems
that the the waste protein suctions are
formed in human bodies
artificial intelligence has also made
amazing
contributions in the field of
agriculture
ai techniques have been used by farmers
to promote agricultural productivity in
performance analysis in early detection
of what i cultural produce to prevent
waste states of agricultural disease
over widely it has been used in
in studying livestock
a mountain livestock on farm
in finding solutions to earth problems
in plants and animals they also have
intelligence sensors that will be
indicated with our
cameras to monitor the farm for pest
infestation also allows the farmers
to make quick decision about the
altercation of pesticides on the farm
for obstruction for best infestation
artificial intelligence has also
postponed gateways to the world of
business
their techniques have been used in
informal sites to perform product
recommendations and telegram advertising
in ai we are able to recommend products
to prosperity customers based on their
differences of previous purchases
especially intensive techniques i'm also
using financial services to
fight for that satisfaction using ai to
monitor financial transactions in real
time to detect part of that transaction
and see reports of widget source
transaction from taking place natural
language processes as big language
barriers in businesses as possible now
translates
an e-commerce site to any language
design example
of translating so many sites on the
internet to different languages
testimony analysis is a branch of
natural language processes that can also
be used
by business
management to analyze
customers couldn't use system whether
their policies are negative which are
very helpful in assisting business
management
in making critical decisions about the
marketing of the quality of their
products artificial intelligence has
also possibly getting into automobile
industry
self-driving cars like tesla certainly
as human self-directors all discuss make
use of advanced visual systems to be
able to drive
communication techniques like object
detection object segmentation have made
it possible for us to have autonomous
vehicles that are capable of studying
their words to
identify obstacles and words avoid
obstacles to step pestering us almost
to detect other verbs blinding woods and
also to their tacticalized onwards
other visions are made it possible for
us to create self-driving cars that are
capable of observing which or without
human assistance
in completion in this talk i have spoke
about what artificial intelligence is
briefly explain the evolution of a.i
different approaches that have been used
in ai to create intelligent machines
the different branches some of different
patches we have in ai of
accessible to everyone
and finally the contribution of
artificial intelligence in medical field
in business in ottawa industry and in
question
thank you so much for listening
thank you ayola
welcome thank you so much for the
wonderful presentation um
thank you so much
so we we will take questions now right
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh and here is your contact information
great
questions raise your hand
it's a wonderful
it's a wonderful tool
that you created
definitely have to look into it
thank you so much
i would like to actually ask you you
know a little bit of uh how did you get
the idea to build that in the first
place
oh
what really motivates me
was you know to make ai easier i've
learned about different aspects of
computer vision but flying in
classification of the detection and i
might just amazing article about all the
segmentation that was
listed as a nice scene and i've never
heard about it before then and i was
surprised that it was actually
technology used in self-driving cars and
stopping physical as problems so and i
also read the papers about some of the
nuances of this increasing objectivation
like master same points rate and
i just said that one of you i can create
a tool that will make it easier for
everyone to be able to apply computer
vision into their sub distribution
because there are so many programmers
out there who are skilled in other
aspects of the program because they have
limited knowledge in ai and they are
willing to apply ai into their work so i
just let me pay this too and i'm happy i
was losing it so and personally it's not
just being used by thousands of
developers across the globe
that is really really cool
was it was it easy finding contributors
because it's an open source project
right so i'm assuming by now you're not
the only one developing on it
i personally are i have to compete
contributors on my detox with city if
you visit my digital city i have a few
contributors but most of it's for some
time because i really have shades are
considerations from different
perspectives i've also made some changes
to
some of my work
um there's a question from mark
uh he said thanks ayola really
interesting he'd love to learn more
about the development of your tools for
exam for example
with the image classifier if you have
used transfer learning
for the image association actually i
changed the model from scotch using
mobile nets moments
who are networking sun
architecture designed for efficiency
oneness what i can one on mobile devices
that was changed
and another um note from uh jordy
um
he said that your talk is his main
motivation to participate in this event
then your work is amazing and
so because you you self-taught yourself
into the field if you could give us any
tips or motivation to do that
that would be really great
okay uh actually when i was young i
always wanted to be a scientist that can
events know a bit about different
scientists like abraham eastern
stars in nicaragua but i've always
wanted to be scientifically visually
scientists it takes several years and a
lot of dedication specimens behind the
lab and starts to get acid exhausting
but when i got into programming i said
programming like if i'm powerful too
that's kind of youtube it's like crazy
problem i just said i want to be an
application i'm doing this and you guys
didn't do that
how's it going
there's a picture to do this and
most interestingly is the aspect of ai
is even much more amazing with ai you
can do a lot of amazing things placing
it so that's capable of know of solving
a problem like one that is capable of
seeing an object and saying now this is
this is a card it's a card it's a person
like woman very interesting like well
this is surely my
my family my passion programming and
that also leads me to ai and that has
made me motivated me to create uh my af
star experience
thank you for answering that is there
any more questions or remarks from
anybody anybody
um
if not we we have a ten minute break
right
is it all
are we on schedule to go on a ten minute
break
um yeah i think we can do that if we
don't have any more questions
but
i really want to thank
ayola for sharing her incredible
tool toolbox and her experience and
knowledge thank you so much ayola yeah
i'm so i'm so grateful you're welcome
there's one more question from your d
would you like to open your mic and ask
it yourself yuri
okay yes better
yeah just just uh
to say that
what uh
what she's doing what she has done in
this library
uh it's very important in many many
areas
uh take into account that one of the
most interesting things
we can do right now
with
deep learning
is to provide meaning
to what we can get using a camera
so imagine how important this can be
for example for those who have some kind
of
visual impairment
or they have
for example to carry out a very
important task in front of a
machine
where if they make a mistake
imagine for example a electric
device and if you do a mistake
your even your security can be risked
so with the work
uh
like this pixel leap library
and this is why we are interested in
what the eula has ariula has done
is it possible
to automatically
get meaning to whatever you have in
front
and to help the user the operator in
order to interpret
to know what is going on so it is
really very interesting this kind of
technology okay because it is going to
help professionals
is going to help uh
disabled people
and uh
this kind of solutions are called to
change
how we are going to interact
with our environment with our world
so uh this pixel leap library
what uh makes is to
uh to do uh our
to work with this uh kind of uh problems
in a much much easier way so i invite
you all
to go to her github
and you will see how easy it is okay and
it is very easy to use it in python
thanks
to the great work of her so
congratulations
thank you so much mr john you know we
have communicated on linkedin and i'm so
grateful for your encouragement
uh i remember there's a particular that
you sent me in an article that was
published on recently but now so good so
thank you so much my encouragement
and i have posted the link to get to the
github on the chat thank you so much
so
uh we will go for a ten minute still 10
minute 10 minute break right
we meet again at quarter
to
eight
all right
yes so
i'm pausing the recording now
okay
so welcome back
and our second speaker is malte tihi so
it's a great pleasure to have him here
since he will talk about how to fix the
mean absolute error
and i'm really looking forward to it
because i guess like many of the people
that attend this meeting have used this
metric in the past so
let's see let's see how we can fix it
and what's wrong with it
before
offering the floor to malta a couple of
things concerning his background
he has pursued
a phd
in theoretical quantum physics
and after his academic research he
joined blue yonder in hamburg as a data
scientist
where he pursued a number of external
and internal projects involving
programming in python
wrangling large amounts of data
evaluating predictions and communicating
the corresponding results
so without further ado
please small down the floor is yours
looking forward to your talk
yeah thank you very much thank you very
much for
having me here that for the opportunity
to to present some of the work that
we're doing let me share my screen
can you see the correct part of my
screen
yes
one with the title page excellent
yeah so um my name is malta i work for
blue yonder that's our office here in
hamburg which i haven't seen in a while
um but this is still what we do so we
develop and run software to run a supply
chain so
we have software to plan manufacturing
the transport of goods dc workforce
management distribution
allocation replenishment all the things
where you have goods coming from a to b
and eventually uh coming to the end
consumer yeah and so fixed word for
actually staying even though i have a
really scary title namely how to fix
mean absolute error using rank
probability score so it will be about
evaluation metrics and talks about
evaluation metrics there's a prejudice
that they are abstract boring and not
really relevant
and that's my main
purpose tonight to convince you of the
opposite
that talking about evaluation metrics is
very relevant when it comes to your
business problem um it it's not always
that abstract it can be made very
concrete and hopefully it will be a
little bit interesting for you
so
um in order to know how to fix mean
absolute error we first need to know
what's broken so we'll need to talk
about what's wrong with mean absolute
error and for that we need some context
so where and how do we actually use mean
absolutely
so that's the agenda of my talk uh
that's where we'll go through so let me
start with where and how we use mean
absolute error and my talk will be a
little bit uh technical but i
i did an effort to really make it um
self-contained so if there's something
unclear i mean please don't hesitate to
interrupt me and to ask a question so i
can clarify
yeah so the context is um predictions
used in supply chain applications so
normally when we talk about predictions
uh we have this dichotomy that either we
have continuous quantities like
temperature or blood pressure or we have
discrete categories we have just seen an
ayola's talk um image classification uh
so here we have categories like uh yeah
what what species is it animal is this
uh foreground is background
and in supply chain applications we
often have a hybrid case because we have
discrete quantities of countable atomic
objects so like red t-shirts so every
time i talk about something that's to be
predicted you can think of the number of
red t-shirts
now that's the quantity because zero is
smaller than one smaller than two and so
on but it's also discrete because i can
never sell 0.7 t-shirts i will never
sell 2.3 t-shirts and so on so i have
this um hybrid case and this is what
i'll focus on uh today because yeah this
is what we
deal with uh when we talk about supply
chain applications
so a bit more context i think you're a
data scientist and you're given this uh
time series of uh t-shirt sales from
2020 so you see these are the t-shirt
sales in time you train a model
in sample and you predict the t-shirt
sales in the future
and
the future will eventually happen the
out-of-sample t-shirt sales will dribble
in
and somebody will ask you well how
good is your forecast how did you do and
that typically breaks down to a question
what's the mean absolute error of that
prediction
so why do people uh often go to mean
absolute error and why do they really
love mean absolute error well in the
first place it's a really easy to write
down quantity isn't it so i have the
observation that i did the actual truth
the reality i subtract my prediction
that i did i take the absolute value and
i do this for many observations many
predictions so i take the mean over all
these observations and predictions
and it makes a lot of sense because
there is a simple business
interpretation uh here that the cost of
being wrong is just proportional to how
wrong we are so think of a situation
where the actual demand of t-shirts was
nine so nine people came into your store
they wanted to buy a red t-shirt
on the x-axis you have your prediction
that you had for that day
for how many t-shirts would be would be
in in demand and you feed this
prediction directly into your
replenishment system so that's also the
number of t-shirts that you have on
stock
so if you have nine t-shirts on stock
and you have nine people who want a
t-shirt that's great everybody gets a
t-shirt
and at the end of the day you don't have
any t-shirts left
you you did all the revenue that you
could have done
if you had an over prediction if for
example you ordered 12 t-shirts then you
will have a cost at the end of the day
because you have three access pieces you
have three t-shirts that were not bought
you have to do something with them you
have to pay the manufacturer in the
first place and maybe tomorrow you will
have to sell them maybe you have to give
a discount that they are sold at all and
it's very reasonable that the cost that
you have with these t-shirts just
increases with the number of access
t-shirts so that this is a straight line
uh going up
now also if you have an under prediction
if you only ordered like six t-shirts
you have a cost because you still have
the actual demand of nine so nine
customers entered wanted to buy a
t-shirt three of them didn't get a red
t-shirt so there's lost revenue and this
revenue that you didn't make because you
didn't have the t-shirts on stock and
you have three unhappy customers so it
also makes sense that the error of your
prediction increases linearly like a
straight line to the left
there is however a really strong
assumption here that is that currently
if we write down like this then assuming
one excess piece um
yeah we're assuming that this is just as
expensive as one missing piece so that
an over prediction is just as costly as
an under prediction
in some business applications this might
be the case and others it might not be
the case just to have in mind that
that's a strong assumption
that this slope is the same as that
slope
now we use mean absolute error to
compare models and we will typically
assume that minimizing mean absolute
error for a given training
cross-validation set this will point us
to the right forecast so we will
i have model a i have model b i will
typically go live with that model that
has a smaller mean absolute error
so we like taking that result is a
really really hard currency it's a
really hard argument i mean we go to
executive level meetings and we show
just that number and say okay we go with
that model or we go with that vendor
because the mean absolute error is
is lower so we treat it as something
very real but let me invent a uh
saying like blindly trusting the
evaluation metric is the most undata
scientific thing that uh you can do so
we will now dig a little bit into the
details and be a bit skeptic whether
mean absolute error always has
the right answer
now yeah it's quite similar simple to
calculate but let's dive into some more
detail about how to calculate it in
practice
namely what happens if you have a
fractional forecast and this will very
uh often happen that your uh system
whatever that forecast is will give you
as one number a fractional number like
9.47 so what do you mean by tomorrow red
t-shirt sales will be 9.47 probably not
this that you have nine t-shirts that
you sell in every case and just half a
t-shirt uh that you didn't sell or yeah
and you sold half a t-shirt uh in excess
this will not happen no problem this is
typically
a probabilistic statement where we
reveal our belief about what will be the
mean sales on such days and there's some
assumption on how these sales will be
distributed uh which can
for example be um
the
uh
the personal distribution i saw there
was a
um
a very good question how do i know the
actual demand if you only have an under
predicted stock yes
so
indeed so if i have just six pieces
if i have these three customers
that they tell me okay i wanted to buy a
t-shirt i didn't find a t-shirt that's
easy
typically if you have a grocery store
that's a very hard question because the
people will not tell you and you will
just see you went out of stock on that
day you sold everything
but strictly speaking you don't know
whether the true demands say you you
ordered six and you sold six you don't
know whether the true demand was six or
seven or eight or maybe even 27.
so that's a really tough problem in um
model building what do you do in these
out of stock situations how do you model
that um
yeah to uh to correctly account for it
for the true demand if you have a very
popular item in only very few few stocks
at the beginning of the day it's very
likely that the true demand was much
higher than
what you had on stock
yeah so back back to the
distribution
so typically we assume something like
the poisson distribution so what we
precisely mean with this is that
we will sell uh nine t-shirts with
probability 13 we might also sell 10
t-shirts with a slightly lower
probability or 11 t-shirts 12 t-shirts
and so on
so what how do we now do to calculate
mean absolute error
i mean we need to plug in an observation
and that's pretty easy because at the
end of the day we sold six or nine or 27
t-shirts so we can just plug in this
number here
but this strictly speaking is not a
number but a distribution so we need to
map this distribution to a number and
that mapping is called a point estimator
and this point estimator i always have
to think about point estimators whenever
i evaluate any evaluation metric where i
need to plug in two numbers
now it turns out that
you can have different point estimators
for different
evaluation metrics so if you have this
distribution here that you predict and
you want to evaluate mean squared error
so where you take the observation minus
prediction squared and you average over
it then the correct point estimated
correct way to summarize the
distribution to a single number is the
mean of the distribution so 9.47
so you can show this in a slightly
formal way but this is like the correct
way to summarize this and to plug in
9.47
but now we are interested in mean
absolute error so for mean absolute
error it turns out that the correct
point estimator is the median of the
distribution so not the expected values
and not what i will get on average but
the value at which the probability
distribution is
divided to two halves with the same
probability weight so
also the median is like implicitly
defined in in that way and the median
turns out in this case to be 9
not 9.47 so we see that for one
distribution one prediction we will have
different numbers depending on how we
want to evaluate
this prediction
so let's summarize how we evaluate mean
absolute error for probabilistic
forecasts we have the challenge that
typically what we get out of our
forecasting system it's a distribution
it's a probabilistic statement and the
observation if we have is just a number
we need to compare them so we summarize
this distribution by the by a number
that has to be the median you can show
that it has to be the median and then we
can compare the median to that
observation and then compute an error
okay so that's what we are we are
talking about um that's the context
probabil probabilistic forecasts of
discrete countable quantities and we see
that the median is playing an important
role
so what's wrong with it so far nothing
went wrong
we can now
investigate how mean absolute error
behaves under different assumptions uh
we will assume that we are correct and
that observations are truly distributed
according to the poisson distribution
um yeah with the rate that we believe in
and in python that's really easy to do
we just import the poisson distribution
from side by stats let's generate an
array of rates between 0 and 15
100 one of them
let's draw 10 000 observations for each
of these rates and let's compute the
achieved mean absolute error
between these
the the rates
uh and the observations that were drawn
out of these distributions so we're
taking the median of the rates and
subtracting the observations taking the
absolute
arrow and then the mean over it so if
you do that you will get
a plot like this one so if you look at
the blue line that's the mean absolute
error as a function of the predicted
rate under the assumption that your
forecast that your probabilistic
forecast is truly correct so you um you
are not biased you don't have any
additional source of noise or so but
just uh because the poisson distribution
has a certain width uh some unavoidable
uh statistical noise you will have a
finite mean absolute error here that has
this shape and you see there are these
kinks um it's somehow this wavy behavior
here and the kings appear exactly at
those points where the median of the
distribution is jumping from one value
to the next so here the median is zero
then it jumps to one then jumps to two
every time there's a jump uh you also
have a little kink here
now you see that this value increases
with the predicted rate so somehow
there's a scaling effect the larger the
numbers that i'm talking about uh the
larger will be the error that it will
deal with often what people do is they
divide um the mean absolute error by the
mean observation
and that's that's a very useful thing to
do because it gives you an account for
the relative error that you do
um but it's important to note it doesn't
really normalize away the scaling effect
because um now this is also not a
straight line i mean this is also
decreasing so for larger rates i can
expect lower
value of my relative error than for very
small rates
so why why is that the case let's have a
look into
some more detail
um here i'm plotting the poisson
distribution for a rate of one so if we
predict one that would be the
probability distribution uh you observe
zero with probability thirty seven point
five percent you observe one with the
same probability you can also observe
two with a substantial probability and
so on
now zero is one hundred percent away
from one so whenever i measure zero and
i have predicted one i'm i have a
relative error of 100 percent
uh same if i observe two i have 100
error and this is why for that
distribution um yeah even if i my my
data perfectly matches this distribution
i have to live with quite a large
relative mean absolute error of around
70 or so
and if i go to larger values of the rate
so here that's a rate of 4 or rate of
100 yeah then the relative width of the
distribution decreases
and i can expect a lower relative mean
absolute
so this is all for an unbiased or
correct poisson forecast um
and yeah so far everything is fine
i have these kinks but they're maybe not
so bad but it turns out that absolute
arrow is discontinuous in
um the rate if i have some over forecast
or under forecast so this is what you
see now as the blue line so the gray
line is for the unbiased case
um now the the blue line is when you
have systematic over forecast
and now you see that this line is
jumping um at the at the point where
there were the kings and this is a very
ugly behavior because you don't you
somehow lose uh your
idea of where your relative mean
absolute error should be and you can
have two situations that are very close
but give a very different uh relative
mean absolute error so let's have a look
in some detail for prediction of 1.7 and
a true rate of 1.42 so i'm over
predicting
um my rmae relative mean absolute error
is around 76
for a very similar situation a
prediction of 1.6 again the 20 percent
forecast my rme is much smaller so i'm
just on the left hand side of this jump
and here i'm on the right hand side of
the jump and the reason for that is that
for a prediction of 1.7 the median has
already jumped to the value of 2. for
the prediction of 1.6 the median is
still sitting at 1.
so we have two situations that are very
similar and if you look at the shape of
the blue curve this is what you predict
the orange curve is what you what you
what you have in reality and you
compared to that by i you can hardly see
any difference
yet the relative mean absolute arrow
takes very different values and it's
it's of course not a nice property
and only if you go to the uh range of
really fast sellers or sort of the fast
movers you find what you expect that
this systematic over forecast by 20
is reflected by a 20
relative mean absolute error
so that's one problem of um
mean absolute error
that is discontinues
now there's another problem that is due
to this median absolute error is also
very course grained you can have one
outcome and many different forecasts
that you would consider best
i mean imagine you sell five t-shirts uh
on on a given day what what was the best
forecast that would match these five
t-shirts if you measured with mean
absolute error well any forecast between
around 4.7 and 5.6 because between 4.7
and 5.6 the median of the distribution
is again five your absolute error is
just zero
and again even though you have two very
different distributions i mean the blue
distribution and the orange distribution
are clearly different they will give you
the same mean absolute error you have no
chance to discriminate
any
prediction in this range of rates here
using mean absolute error so it's also
called grained it's not very precise
finally absolute error is useless for
very small predictions i know useless is
a very strong word but i think you can
really say that um because if your
prediction is smaller than 0.69
you don't see any impact of any bias
anymore so for
above 0.69 you see that there's this
gray line for the unbiased case and the
bias has induced a jump in the relative
mean absolute error so you would you
would measure the bias in the relative
mean absolute error
but for all that range down here um the
bias and the unbiased case give you this
very same value of rme
namely 100
and this is because
uh
below 0.69
the median is always zero independently
whether your rate is 0.6 just a little
bit below 0.69 or 0.06 or 0.006 so you
have again very different distributions
that you cannot distinguish using mean
absolute error and the resulting rmae is
always 100 percent because rme that's
the mean of observation minus prediction
divided by the mean of the observation
but my prediction
has to be the median of the distribution
since my distribution uh yeah
is a
is one with a median of zero i just
subtract zero so i have mean of
observation divided by mean of
observation
yeah that's that's very boring i can
always tell you that uh whenever your if
your prediction is smaller than 069 your
rmae will be 100 and you didn't learn
anything about
whether this is a good forecast or bad
forecast
so that's what is um yeah these are the
issues of mean absolute error we saw
this discontinuous behavior we saw that
it's cause-grained and it's a very
problematic not to say useless for for
slow settlers
so what can we do to to improve this
let's let's try to to fix it and for
that um
yeah let's let's look again how we came
to evaluate mean absolute error so again
i mean we had a distribution an
observation
we want to compare the distribution to
the observations and somehow we have to
get to a number there's only one way to
get to that number the media
before jumping into it there's there's a
question
because it's related to what you just
wrapped up so sorry to draft
um yeah yes
are there similar useless thresholds for
example of a gamma distributed demand
for other type of distributions that is
um
good question yeah so
when you're
um
demands so here i'm assuming that the
eventual demand is a discrete quantity
so i mean you could for example have a
negative binomial
um distributed
demand um
yeah let's say the general phenomenon is
that if your median is zero um yeah then
it's then it's very boring because then
you uh simply predict zero and you will
be off by your mean mean observation
that should be independent of the
distribution i guess
now gamma would be a continuous
distribution
um
so
that would be
used here as the as a distribution of
your
selling rate
um yeah so i i would say you know it's
not bound to the personal distribution
it's bound to the fact that the median
is uh zero yeah
i hope all of this answers the question
otherwise please let me know
um
yeah and there's another comment um
am i following correctly then that for
high volumes uh mean absolute errors
more robust yeah that's that's uh
correct and
yeah in a sense it hurts less i mean the
problems that we have seen are really
the problems that you have when you are
talking about intermediate values
of of units so when you predict
something about 5 or 10 or 15 or so so
if you always predict something of at
least 1 000 um and you're sure it's
possible distributed then these problems
don't affect you that that badly
yeah thanks for the questions um
feel free to ask more questions um
yeah so we we now want to want to fix
this and look at
how we we came to evaluate mean absolute
error we saw we have to summarize it by
the median and then we take the error so
what can we change with this process
here i mean there's this little that we
can do
one number minus the other number
um i mean we want to keep this absolute
error here because we saw there is a
business interpretation so this is
something we don't want to touch we also
don't want to touch the media on because
if you use the mean instead of the
median you will have a biased forecast
so
it will actually push you always to a
mean of zero when you have uh very
slowly selling items um
so change the that medium median is also
not an option so there's not much that
we can do there's one thing that we can
do we can exchange the order of these
two operations so instead of first
summarizing and then computing the error
we can take a deep breath and we can
first compute the error for each
possible outcome
each outcome that we predicted
we can compute the error to the
observation so now we have many errors
it looks like this
so to speak so we have one observation
all the different outcomes and compute
and error and then we somehow need to
summarize these errors by some uh
average okay
so um we simply yeah change the order of
these two two operations and see what uh
what comes out now what would be a
meaningful way to average these uh these
errors here uh well probably the the
probability that you assigned to it a
priori is a good way so
um this one here we predicted nine to
happen with probability 13 percent uh
the actual outcome is 13 so we should
probably give that error
a large weight that or a slightly uh
smaller one and so on and yeah we also
predicted that one could happen and
maybe 0.1 percent of the cases we should
also take that into account but with
very very tiny weight okay so we take a
weighted
mean of the the all the possible errors
that
we had predicted
okay so formally uh what we would do is
we would sum over all the possible
outcomes um yeah between zero and
infinity we wait by the probability that
we assigned to that outcome i mean we
before the event happened we had a
certain uh belief what's the probability
to see see the event we wait by that
probability and then we have the
absolute error between that outcome and
the uh and the
observation okay so let's call this um
absolute error star like absolute error
improved formally speaking you can also
say it's the expectation value of
outcome minus observation when outcome
is distributed like your prediction if
you like this mathematical way of
formulating things now it turns out
there's this one thing that we need to
do to have a proper evaluation metric um
because currently it's not minimal for
the best prediction we need to correct
it by um
something that accounts for the width of
the predicted probability distribution
to get to what will actually fix the
absolute error and that's called the
rank probability score so that's this ae
star that we defined above minus the
expectation value of
the difference between two outcomes if i
draw
two outcomes out of my prick
distribution okay so rps rank
probability score is
answering
the question how far is the observation
from my predicted distribution in a
meaningful way and subtracts how distant
are two random outcomes from that
distribution so how broad is the
distribution
so that's called rank probability score
now you might ask okay why is it called
rank probability score we could call it
weighted
weighted absolute error or something
well because now the way i explained
this to you was um yeah i tried to bring
this a little bit to the business world
and say well this is a good estimate of
your business loss
to have this rps but it's also known in
the statisticians world in a much more
abstract way where you say well it's
it's somehow the difference in the space
of cumulative
distribution functions and has really
nice abstract properties so
um yeah it just turns out that there is
this connection between something that
statisticians
like and something that yeah is
meaningful um in the business world
and yeah so statisticians call it rank
probability score for which reason um
yeah do we we use that name rank
probability score
so let's look at some edge cases for
example a deterministic forecast
and now a deterministic forecast means
my predicted probability distribution
has only one possible outcome so
probability is one for nine units of
sale and all the others i uh say a
priori the probability is zero
yeah the the median of that distribution
is obviously nine and then after media
nine i subtract the observation 13 i get
the error that is four here
and here for deterministic forecast
there's no difference in
uh when i now first compute the error
for each possible outcome because
there's only one possible outcome i mean
determinism means i i expect there's
only one outcome possible namely nine i
have that error here the only error that
that counts and that's the only error
that will appear in this weighted
average so for deterministic forecasts
this thing that i just introduced the
rank probability score is the very same
thing as absolute error as you already
know it
now
uh if you want to evaluate rank
probabilities for in python numerically
it's quite simple if you have a
probability mass function of what you
predicted
um and you
uh yeah can just
uh
take the sum over uh that's the
probability mass function and the
absolute error between uh your
observation and uh yeah the different
outcomes uh for for this part of the
expression and something slightly
uh more complicated but also still quite
simple um for that expression here
now this is very simple to write down
but it becomes numerically very
expensive
and thankfully there are some close
expressions if you have a poisson or a
negative binomial distribution you can
look them up in the paper um where you
can find here the rank probability score
for a given observation um in
it's it's very abstract but but you can
find it in the paper so you can
implement it uh in a much more efficient
way
um using the formulas of that paper
so we can now evaluate this rank
probability score and compare it to mean
absolute error and let's do this again
for a fixed observation so we are again
in that situation that we have um yeah
the truth is nine so there
nine people came and wanted to buy a red
t-shirt the blue line is absolute error
and the orange line is ranked
probability score so you see that the
overall shape is quite similar but there
are a few differences let's go through
that step by step so in the first place
for a prediction of zero the poisson
distribution has with zero um it's just
telling you uh the the event the outcome
will be zero so that's a deterministic
forecast so rps and absolute error take
the same value so it makes a lot of
sense that the two
functions meet here when you have a
prediction of zero
now in the middle
when our predicted mean is nine and in
principle matches the observation rps is
a bit more conservative a bit skeptic i
mean you have a finite error even though
your outcome matched um the the
prediction but if you predicted uh nine
on average
you you predicted nine only to appear
with a finite probability so
uh if you predict nine then your belief
is this orange distribution here so you
you think it will be nine only with
thirteen percent of the cases it could
also be twelve or l uh eleven or uh
actually six
sorry
nine it could be eight or seven or six
uh and so on so
rps in a sense knows that and will give
you a finite error here when uh you
match the um
the the mean value
but on the other hand rps is much more
relaxed much more tolerant if you are
close to
the the predicted mean so it only
increases a little bit when you go one
step to the right or two steps to the
right um taking into account that yeah
this outcome of nine could also have
been produced by um a probability
distribution of mean seven or mean eight
or one with a mean eleven um yeah so if
you predict a mean of 11 you you still
predict quite a substantial probability
to observe nine so when you observed
nine this is not a very surprising thing
and it's not being yeah the cost of this
is not being set
very high here
and if you go very far away um then um
rank probability score just becomes mean
absolute error minus
a constant which is smallest
the width of the distribution so now you
might say well these are all nice
properties but i mean does rps really
fix these problems that we saw i mean i
said we have these problems it's
discontinuous cost grained and it's
useless for slow sellers so let's check
this um yeah the first place it is
actually continues here we have the same
plot as before uh where we plot uh the
evaluation metric as a function of the
uh predicted rate which here is equal to
the true rate so we have a perfect model
um again for very large rates they come
come very close and here in between
somehow the behavior is more smooth and
doesn't have these kinks and also when i
have a biased forecast um
yeah i still have a continuous line here
so that that red line is still smooth
and continuous
now rank probability score is also much
more fine-grained and mean absolute
error and has a well-defined minimum um
yeah i'm showing you the same picture as
before so that's absolute arrow which
has this plateau here it just takes the
value zero all the way for a predictive
rate from 4.7 to 5.6 while rank
probability score yeah is is smooth and
has a real minimum at exactly the rate
of five so rank probability score will
be able to uh distinguish these
distributions um
yeah
uh
uh and yeah uh will will give you this
better discrimination
discriminatory power
yeah finally rank probability score can
also distinguish very small rates uh
we saw the problem before was that um
the
line for bias of 1.2 and a line for no
bias or bias one they just took the same
value here um for mean absolute error so
it's all this
boring plateau so to speak now rank
probability score still allows you to do
some differentiation so you will still
feel a bias in the rank probability
score um
also for
very small uh rates although
the sensitivity will be decreasing i
mean you you cannot expect miracles here
but uh
in principle it's still usable for slow
sellers
yeah so i hopefully convinced you that
rank probability score fixes the
problems that we saw at the beginning
instead of this discontinuous jump
behavior with continuous behavior
instead of this imprecise cause grain
behavior it's now much more fine grained
we saw that mean absolute error is very
probably problematic for slow movers
here it is in principle you uh usable
for slow movers even though yeah you
shouldn't expect
miracles
so that's how um yeah we went through
how and where do we use mean absolute
error we saw a few problems with it and
how we can solve it if we take
seriously the probabilistic aspect of
our forecast and this might lead you to
to comment like
why do we need probabilistic forecasts
at all i mean um why do we need that
uncertainty if you have the choice
between this forecast where you are
promised to have uh to sell nine items
on a given day versus this forecast
which is somehow telling me yeah maybe
you sell nine items maybe sell ten maybe
you sell even four you would go for that
one
and that's a very general tendency that
people
very much like to to have um yeah exact
and deterministic statements i mean
maybe you've seen uh don't look up
there's the scene where the phd student
comes in and says well you know there's
a comet and it will would will hit earth
with 99.78 probability we have to act
now and the reaction is ah okay great so
it's it's not 100
and yeah so so i think there's a general
thing people put a lot of value on a
deterministic not so good solution over
a probabilistic but maybe much better
solution and it's not only for
predictions it's also maybe the case for
vaccines for treatments for investments
and i can understand that that you want
determinism of course but there are laws
of nature i mean here we explore some
laws of statistics in general the world
is quite complex and if you have a
forecast it will never be 100 certain
making that uncertainty explicit yeah it
shouldn't be a sign of weakness but
really of trustworthiness um
yeah it seems sometimes that if you have
a statement like this one like oh it's a
probability distribution is a little bit
you know to evade uh falsifiability
because you can predict this
and yeah independently of what's the
outcome you always have predicted every
outcome with a certain probability isn't
it but on the long term also statistical
statements are true or false so also on
the long term um
yeah when you have several measurements
you can say is this a true prediction or
a bad prediction
so yeah ai ml uh is not only about
reducing uncertainty and will
never
reach absolute certainty but uh it's a
lot about optimally understanding and
dealing with the unavoidable uncertainty
so
back to um since the
with uh i think we already touched this
a little bit in the questions so if your
predictions and observations are like in
a medium range like they could be 4 or
10 or 15
then at least for the porcelain
distribution using the entire
probability distribution instead of just
a point estimator this has a large
impact i mean you then really feel these
problems that mean absolute error has
and it's a good idea to use rank
probability score
if you have super fast movers if
everything is larger than say 20
then um at least for the poisson
distribution just
yeah this wave this uncertainty is not
that crucial
um yeah the usage of mae will probably
give you more or less the same results
as a rank probability score and yeah
using any is probably okay
and if your predictions and observations
are extremely small
then i would actually question uh that
you're on the right aggregation scale i
mean does your mean absolute error
really reflect the business case
for example if you have a forecast that
tells you will sell 0.5 t-shirts per day
does it make sense to evaluate the
forecast on a daily basis because you're
not taking any decision on the daily
basis on your teachers i mean you're not
throwing away the t-shirts after one day
you're not replenishing the t-shirts
every day
probably there it makes more sense to
aggregate an entire month
or even a longer
period of time so if you encounter such
numbers i mean check the aggregation
scale this is really the right thing to
compare but we saw that in doubt rps has
a better um
is behaving in a better way
yeah so maybe you don't deal at all with
red t-shirts uh with the problems that
you do um yeah very much in general
still don't rely on what you hope your
scoring will reflect i mean be a data
scientist so test your scoring
functionally against uh controlled cases
tested against what you think is the
ideal case against some biased or
inaccurate cases against imprecise cases
against cases of outliers to really
understand what what that metric uh is
doing
in order to yeah eventually take the
right business decision because yeah we
are not optimizing metrics just for the
sake of optimizing metrics but at the
end of the day we want to provide some
value
yeah so if you're interested in in that
today we published um a blog post on a
related topic uh on the hindsight
selection bias that you have when you
evaluate forecast so if you're
interested feel free to
jump on that
the blog and
yeah i'd be more than happy to to answer
any question that you might have and
thanks a lot for staying in for
listening
great thanks molly that was really
nicely explained and
very insightful
we have questions so
jordy maybe it is a stupid question
which is never the case
but can we say that the advantages you
are describing us with rps versus
mean absolute error will be used in cost
sensitive learning where for example
under prediction and over predictions
could have different weights when
talking about money
yes i think i think there are two um two
issues here so one one is the difference
between a deterministic forecast and
probabilistic forecast before the
probabilistic forecast uh rps is say the
way to go now you you are mentioning the
example of um
an
uns
symmetric cost
function so you an underestimate would
have a different cost than an over
estimate so maybe let's jump to to that
slide um
so you would probably have a have a cost
function that has a different slope on
the right hand side
then on the on the left hand side
um
now i'm wondering
whether yeah so probably you could also
adjust rps in a way that it also
reflects this asymmetry
i haven't thought about it but um yeah
in principle if you have both so you
have a probabilistic forecast and you
have an asymmetric cost function you
should be able to to modify that um
that evaluation metric in a way that it
really points you towards your
optimal solution
yeah so i don't know does this answer
the question so i would say no
not out of the box but it should be
possible to to adapt it to to reflect uh
your use case
yeah jordy says yes so um
another one comes from
mt i'm sorry i forgot your name so i say
mt my apologies
uh super interesting mother thanks uh
one question how does mean square error
compare with the mean absolute error for
those effects
yes so um yeah so so for mean squared
error the optimal point estimator is
just a mean and since the mean is uh
continuous you don't have all these jump
uh jumps and all this jumping behavior
so indeed so mean squared error um yeah
it doesn't suffer from those those
problems that are
that have shown let me go to one slide
yeah i mean i mean squared error
is continuous it's also fine grained and
formally yeah it will also not not have
this this property here for the slow
sellers um
yeah i mean squared error has then the
disadvantage that the business
interpretation is not so straightforward
because it it puts a much higher cost to
every next step you go away from from
your um
from from your target isn't it so yeah
indeed i mean you don't have these
formal problems but you also lose the
the business interpretation and
um i mean in our our case this
the the business case is really there i
mean yeah if i'm two pieces off uh i
have half the cost then if i'm four
pieces off
so um
any more questions for malta maybe did i
miss something
um
as you can see people love the talk so
excellent i have a question like from a
practical standpoint because at some
point you mentioned uh you gave some
reference to some papers you said okay
you can check the formulas and implement
them
that's definitely doable but
some people might not feel so
comfortable they don't have the time to
invest in developing like even simple
functions like that so
is there like an already existing python
packets r package or something that you
wrote that it's freely available
um yes it is definitely an our package
um
let me look it up i will then uh post
the name in the i'll be great because
everyone exploring
scoring functions or something um
yeah let me let me look it up um
and then i will i will post it into the
chat so that there's
um in our package um
yeah so
i haven't seen a python package so far
um
yeah so
we have some
now proprietary um things that we have
developed so we're also talking about
open open sourcing maybe some some of it
is at some stage um yeah currently it's
not not yet open sourced
yeah but i will i will post the vr
package sure sure just you know because
what you pointed out is is very
important so a lot of people might want
to use it but then you know they don't
have the
they import x and so on and forth you
know yeah i mean you will
yeah if you do it like this
you will have only a little bit of fun
at the beginning and then you will
suffer from the computational
expenses the same
this looks very very
tiny and innocent but it will be very
expensive
okay
there is a question from mert is there
any documentation for rps
yeah so there
are papers like in the biases
biostatistics
world yeah i mean maybe
if you start in that one there's also
papers by by goodnight maybe i can i can
um yeah sure share a link to to a paper
to a survey paper
um
where they when they discuss it a bit
yeah
i'll be great
more questions maybe
i have one that is a bit more on the
kind of like a
human cognitive biases kind of you know
side of things not like on the technical
side so i mean you you made it explicit
at the end that we are not comfortable
with uncertainty and that
many times is interpreted as oh okay you
cannot really make a good accurate model
and so on so i shouldn't bother or
something like that if people are not
into the details of what this exactly
means like modeling things in a
probabilistic way
so i don't know if you would like to
share like
experiences with that if it's hard to
drive this um
type of modeling approaches to customers
like to to really pin down the points
and why they're useful is there like a
lot of resistance or like people are
more receptive
yeah it's it's it actually it can be
quite tough because so now forecasts
have uh gone from being on maybe monthly
or weekly level to really be on the
lowest level so on on daily level and
then if you're on daily level the the
numbers that you look at are often just
small numbers i mean you predict uh
three
and then you observe four and then you
are which is a fantastic predict
everything is fine isn't it if you
predict it free and uh according to the
personal distribution four is a totally
acceptable outcome
um
yeah but
i mean i have had this this discussion
with customers really telling them yeah
you will
you want that determinism but you will
not get it and because
already pushing it down to person with
is is very tough often you are wider
than also i mean personal is already um
a good case i mean it's it's a benchmark
case
where you say okay if you reach the
personal limit if your forecast is
yeah following the poisson distribution
i mean then you you're done for the day
you're
you're quite happy so
indeed there's a um
there's quite some resistance when it
comes to these small numbers and then
you have these large relative errors and
this is why i emphasize at the end so
maybe you're on the on the wrong
aggregation
scale because if you're talking about
something that sells once per day
you're not interested what is your error
on today and tomorrow but you can just
sum today's and tomorrow sales together
and maybe even
next week sales and have
and talk about uh larger numbers because
you the the decision that you eventually
want to take based on that forecast
is not a decision that you're taking on
um
on a daily granularity but you will
aggregate uh several weeks and
then say okay do i want to replenish my
red t-shirts or um will they sell out
yourself
yeah i mean it's a continuous uh effort
that
that we have uh yeah once these four
cards go into this uh green level
granular level that there's still value
because if you aggregate them then the
wave of course decreases
then
you're predicting 30 pieces in one month
and then you can be pretty sure it's
between 25 and 35 or so
right
um
more questions maybe
if not
please let's thank again malte for this
really informative talk
and thanks yeah we are open to
network and
chat a bit i guess if people want to
stick around so
perhaps we could uh end finish the
recording and then we go for the
networking thing that we are more
relaxed
[Music]
good idea yeah let's let's let's do it
like that